welcome to this video five-minute game
against teeter all die don't die
whatever probably ok but the most
important thing is happy new year if i'm
not mistaken um it should be the first
video to be released in 2014 so hope all
of you add some nice some new years eve
spend it with some friends on however
you like it all right this game let's
see we cutter Cecilia hyper accelerated
dragon with Queen deform the Sun and
this line is some pretty solid for black
zone nothing too I'm yeah too exciting
for white sometimes you get them with
Bishop c6 you get this some slightly
compromised pawn structure i'm not sure
that i really should take but yeah yeah
it's not really much even if i take it's
got a very very decent position
especially the bishop on g7 and the long
run is a very useful piece now now is
trying to trying to make sure that it
can recapture with a piece on c6 that
some very sensible reasoning
hmm yeah so not easy at all 22 to get
something in this position
maybe I can provoke him a bit I mean if
I was really a bad move but you never
know maybe he's playing it anyway yeah
well he didn't he didn't help me in any
way yeah my t5 would be it would be nice
but the ante is taking me to this is not
helping at all maybe I can attack e7
like Bishop see 626 Bishop Queenie 7 and
if you place the upon and the sexes is
weak Oh yet I he could have played naija
form maybe this probably would have been
a good move ok I'm going to prevent that
yeah well it would be yeah should
probably move the bishop bag
yeah but then be five yeah i simply i
simply don't have trace of an advantage
here so just a final position for black
maybe i can double on the default yeah
black is very comfortable I probably
should have enough play to to not be in
serious trouble but carol before and
Quincy do it probably yeah I did I
really overlook this yeah nothing you
can do on before I have 94 though but
it's got between and it's got 95 then
who I can take 96 okay this is quite
lucky that this is looking at least it
doesn't look like something I'm too
terrible happening and if it doesn't
have a really really convincing move
exactly now I can play something like
Bishop g5 and to harass the night and
probably rook t7 mmm yeah I can can play
something like that it's a nothing too
exciting but playable yeah maybe 94 even
that I didn't really expect because of
rook t6 not too terrible for black but
okay I well he's arguing that tail at
the end he will get to the sea to pawn I
see the point okay but I hope I should
be able to not be in serious trouble I
take him there are various technical
ideas oh I forgot that is controlling
before hmm that's bad I was always
relying on taking and a 94 I but I just
so i can i can go here this is what i
can do takes Bishop takes should or i
can even take here
if he takes on be too i have 93 so
anyway to play for win here probably not
no no not really yeah we will exchange a
point for people and then it's just the
damn position girl Alfred come around
yeah that he offered the draw and I have
no point of doing anything it's just
it's just dead disposition yeah this is
this wasn't too great I mean maybe I
should have taken c6 when I sled the
chance to spoil this pawn structure a
bit like here it doesn't really promise
much but maybe this was still more
interesting I don't know reroute the
bishop earlier the way it was played
them like was perfectly all right little
tease here and then maybe this is this
is definitely bad because of Najaf
failed to play and now I've got good
real trouble as for really big oversight
the main thread i need to play very ugly
move now like this here black ass and
excellent shape just being quite
substantially better probably I didn't
do that and hear him I suppose it's
about equal I could of trick I what I
was I was thinking like this that this
would be okay right here 195 I can take
it play Knight b6 this is far
but in fact you can just play the smooth
the smooth just attacking it and I don't
really have a very good news to protect
hey gab like it's a very good shape yeah
this didn't really this is always so
tricky kind of set up with a knight on
c3 the porn on c2 and black has this
pressure you really what you would like
to do is to have the night somewhere
else and place III but it didn't work
out so I'm pretty much out played here
but all here this should be okay again
and I guess this oh look the aid oh I
forgot about this move this is his neck
very easy tactic and yeah the sometimes
happens if you have something planned
beforehand of course after before I I
instantly took on c4 because this is
what I had planned but rock d 8 is not
too too difficult gamble here there you
can't take him and so play for an
advantage after this it's just
completely completely dead so yeah this
didn't really convince when I got from
the opening alright thanks for watching